we just got exclusive Benchmark leaks
for the upcoming iPhone 15 Pros a17
bionic chip and just by looking at these
scores you guys are finally going to
understand why I've been calling the
last couple of apple chips stop gaps
like the a16 ship which is apparently on
four nanometer but it's now been proven
that there is no physical difference
between tsmc's previous 2nd Gen 5
nanometer so in this video I'm gonna
reveal those crazy scores for the a17
chip but first I want to mention why
it's so powerful well first of all we
had reports last year that the a17 ship
and the M3 will be built using tsmc's
three nanometer process and we know that
for sure because Apple has already
ordered the entire supply of tsmc's
three nanometer chips for the iPhone 15
Pro and M3 Max and we even got reports
about the amount of chips that they've
started making since late December 45 39
nanometer Wafers per month by March
which I think is enough to meet the a17
and M3 demand so this is what Apple was
waiting for in vain during all of 2022
with those five nanometer stop Gap chips
we're gonna get a huge performance boost
with the a17 so no wonder we've been
getting more and more reports of tsmc's
three nanometer being better than
expected and reports that the iPhone 15
Pro's next-gen chip capabilities will
spark upgrade demand among current
iPhone owners yes there will be a ton of
people who will upgrade when they see
the performance but before I move on
I've got to talk about the best macsafe
iPhone case I've ever seen the magic
stand case from our partner k-sku not
only is it surprisingly slim and durable
but it comes with a very strong 48
Magnet maxafe ring that actually doubles
as a stand just pull out the ring to use
it as a finger grip or as a stand for
watching videos at any angle between 40
and 120 degrees and the best part is
that it folds back completely flush with
the case so you can still use it with
your max save Chargers and accessories
so check out the link and all the
discount info in the video description
below so without further Ado I want to
get into this leak and I want to show
you how it started I replied to a tweet
by Michael on Twitter showing that the
s23 got a big performance boost with
geekbench 6 with the latest update so I
made a funny joke reply saying Samsung
quick how could we optimize for the new
geekbench 6 and I got a reply with the
Benchmark leak right here but it was
actually deleted by the author and he
even deleted his entire Twitter so that
makes it seem like he knew something
that we don't so without further Ado
here it is as you can see there was
somebody that replied to me saying Apple
incoming dot mind blowing with a
geekbench 6 CPU score right here now if
you think this is fake I can assure you
that it is not because of the
combination of the single core and the
multi-core score as you can see
3986 is absolutely insane and just to
show you look at this the highest
geekbench 6 single core score right now
is
3063 with the Intel I9
13900ks a brand new 13th gen Intel chip
now of course this is not overclocked
this is Factory but it's the highest
score we've ever seen and the big thing
you have to notice here is that this UI
is a smartphone UI it's completely
different than the one you get on
computers running it on computer apps
this is a smartphone test as you can see
it's thirty percent faster than the
fastest Intel chip in terms of single
core score but the Banger here in terms
of the evidence is the multi-core it's
only 8 800 points which is nowhere near
what that same chip gets for example
that chip gets 21
000 not 8 800 and that means it's an
iPhone chip this is a prototype a17
bionic chip score yes prototype but the
craziest thing about that multi-core
score is that it actually beats out the
M1 MacBook airs multi-core score of 8258
points yes the a17 bionic iPhone 15 Pro
will be faster than an M1 MacBook Air
and of course we can also see the M2
Chip in the 16 inch MacBook Pro the
single core is 2700 so obviously this
a17 chip is a lot faster and just in
case you you're wondering how that
compares to the a16 ship and the iPhone
14 pro Max this got
2437 for the single core so the a17 will
be 63 faster yes 63 which is a massive
Improvement and guess what that same
Improvement is coming to multi-core as
well 63
faster 8841 compared to 54 30. that is
finally a good Improvement for Apple's
chips no more stopgap a15 a16 that is a
good Improvement but wait it gets even
better if we compare this score from the
a17 to the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 within the
s23 and yes that's after the update that
improved geekbench 6 performance look at
that the single core score is literally
over two times more powerful than the
best chip on an Android phone and then
in terms of the multi-core it's 80
percent fast faster that is absolutely
mind-blowing and now you guys will
understand why so many people are going
to be upgrading to the iPhone 15 Pro now
however there is a catch because I was
able to message this Twitter user who
now has a deleted account but he replied
to me confirming that it was a prototype
a17 chip within the iPhone 15 Pro but
there's a little bit of an issue because
this is a prototype result and he says
that the heat is going to be excessive
so it gets very hot while running this
test and other tests so apparently apple
is going to have to cut down the
performance to maintain the heat so
realistically we probably won't see the
score this good so maybe if we take 10
off the top of the performance we're
gonna see around 3 500 for single core
and around 8 000 for multi-core so it's
still going to be basically the fastest
single course score ever out of any chip
even with them cutting down the power to
make the heat work well but now what
about the GP
sure a lot of you guys are asking for
leaked benchmarks on that but
unfortunately we don't have them however
there is even better news for the GPU
because Apple apparently canceled a Next
Generation GPU potentially with Ray
tracing for the current a16 Bionic chip
thanks to engineering problems now if
you didn't already know geeker one on
YouTube confirmed that the a16 is
actually less efficient than the a15 in
terms of the GPU and why does that make
sense well that's because the a16 uses
faster Ram which means it uses more
power so it's not as efficient but going
even further geeker one confirmed that
Apple literally copy and pasted the same
GPU into the a16 chip from the a15 so
there's literally no difference at all
Apple scrapped the next-gen GPU and
they're holding it off until the a17
ship but wait it gets even better not
only is the a17 gonna have a next-gen
GPU redesign but it's also going to be
built on three nanometer so it's going
to take advantage from both of those at
the same time leading to a massive boost
in performance for the graphics as well
but it doesn't end there because we also
have to talk about the efficiency which
is going to boost battery life now I
don't know if you saw this but the
iPhone 14 pro Max almost performed as
well as the Asus Rog phone 6 in terms of
battery life but the crazy thing is the
iPhone only has a 4300 milliamp hour
battery while the Android phone the Asus
had a 6 000 milliamp hour battery so 40
percent larger and almost the same
battery life but guess what the iPhone
15 Pro is gonna have a larger battery
and that's because the cads for the 15
Pro were released by Max Weinbach and
you can see the difference in thickness
look at that the new one is clearly
thicker than the current iPhone 14 pro
and that of course was the official cads
leaked by Max Weinbach which you can see
right here and in case you think these
are fake it was actually confirmed to
have thinner bezels like this with 2.5 D
Glass by another leak which had the
actual front glass leak showing the
curve and the ultra thin bezels matching
up to what Max winebox said but getting
back to the battery life improvement
with the a17 chip we had a report that
the a17 bionic chip could be 35 percent
more energy efficient enabling longer
battery life thanks to three nanometer
from tsmc so essentially we're gonna
have the fastest chip ever made in a
smartphone coming to the iPhone 15 Pro
we're getting a huge GPU redesign and
we're getting a big boost in battery
life all at the same time and not only
that but we have even more leaks
pointing to a titanium frame solid state
buttons a periscope lens on the Promax
more RAM eight gigs instead of six Wi-Fi
6E and USB type-c maybe even Thunderbolt
so this is going to be a banger redesign
upgrade with the iPhone 15 Pro and tons
of people are gonna upgrade especially
for this absolutely insane leaked
Benchmark score so with that said let me
know your thoughts on this leak down in
the comment section below and click the
circle above to subscribe so that said
so with that said let me know your
thoughts on this leak down in the
comment section below that's what that
said so with that said let me know your
thoughts on this leak down in the
comments below and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign